Posted
by
Okusuzuki Oh, that face You
seem to be wondering why I know your true identity Why did you go out of your
way to aim at a place like this
?  I'm a human
Yuki-san's background Everything is being tracked by the system, including my super.
It's fun to be in the body, but it's a
little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit
I want you to write Fujimoto right now because you can't believe it all of a sudden
.
I've been running around like that, but I'm sorry
. The sound I put in has been protected by Ea in this city since long before Zaki-sama.
I also know that he's been haunting, so I've been
cleverly disguised like this to keep him
safe.It's the role of justice to let Takumi Arc through,
and that's why I'm still dying to help those in need.
Does that mean that you are on our side?
Did you know that it was a good declaration of war in both home and China?